o
per essere qui siamo di sabato siamo in
prima mattina per un hacker questo è un
momento in cui sorridente si dorme
perché come vedremo a breve gli hacker
hanno una tendenza city avere intuizioni
ma assolutamente accade di notte per cui
questo periodo della giornata
solitamente
si cerca di riposare il nostro inconscio
per avere le intuizioni
parliamo quindi di intuizione in touche
con i kings e appunto nuove tecnologie
che l'intuizione è estremamente
importante per un hacker perché
l'intenzione decide di via c da
quell'obiettivo ci da quell elemento che
ci fa andare avanti noi stiamo facendo
un lavoro quando stiamo attaccando un
sistema quando stiamo attaccando
cercando di capire meglio una tecnologia
quindi appunto l'intuizione è uno degli
strumenti
principali uno dei mezzi una delle
coppie che young utilizzano per vedere
cosa c'è dietro un sistema per intuirne
sua funzione e quindi
capi capirlo per poterlo forzare per
poter operare da questa sera di nuovo
parliamo di intuizione la definizione ed
intuizione che tu mia cara è di un segno
che la scritta tanti tanti tanti anni fa
parlo della definizione di carl gustav
jung in cui l'intuizione è una delle
quattro funzioni psichiche da mentali è
una percezione inconscia è il modo in
cui
il nostro inconscio ci insegna a vedere
le cose ci propone delle idee già belle
e pronte
la mente cose diciamo ho idea la
fatidica lampadina anche di archimede
l'eureka
perché il nostro inconscio a questa
facoltà di vedere cose altrimenti non
riusciamo a vedere e che quindi
telefona qual è il problema qual è
affascinante dell'intuizione quando
abbiamo azione
diamo a capire perché questa intenzione
la risposta era di solito non lo so
è ovviamente importante concerto di
intuizione
perché perché anche nella scienza nella
fisica che arrivano tra le scienze
considerate più complesse e tutto è
estremamente importante
lo scienziato ha un'idea a un'intuizione
che gli la l'obiettivo non era vedere la
cosiddetta tesi e quindi i posteri se
non è la scienza lo stesso
troveranno il modo di dimostrare di
capire quali sono i processi logici e
razionali che sono appunto dietro questa
questo esattamente parte diciamo del
pensiero anche scientifico non a caso
questo concetto è confermato anche da
una famosa citazione di einstein in cui
dice che l'unica cosa che ha veramente
valore e appunto l'intuizione
ma chi è maker o e che ho loacker
possiamo esistono tante
linguistiche perché in realtà è più
corretto in italiano lo spazio lager
l'ho scritto con la mostra una dati che
in questa licenza
la parola quindi hacker ha molti
significati fino a che anno fa
votazione negativa echi
e commette dei crimini attraverso
computer information technology e cela
in realtà è questa e una definizione
appunto da liverani 1 un hacker
culturale uno è stato uno dei maggiori
promotori anche della cultura teatri
d'italia è una persona che ha una forte
preparazione tecnica ed è importante
questo concetto di preparazione tecnica
anche per avere intuizioni
soprattutto che si questo è un dato
importante a trafficare con le macchine
con l'hardware e il software può valere
anche benissimo dal concerti filoso
colturali e inventare generare cose
nuove qual è quindi il primo ingrediente
per l'intenzione per un hacker abbiamo
detto che è l'impegno
quell'impegno che uno ci mette a
studiare un sistema per studiare un
libro per approfondire un aspetto di una
tecnologia o di cose meno anche
tecnologiche
questo perché perché se è vero che gaia
sensi dice dell'intuizione sapete
importante edison ci dice che il genio è
il un per cento ispirazione ma anche il
99 per cento di traspirazione di sudore
e di fatica l'impegno che mettiamo
perché è meglio le cose
questo che cosa vuol dire mitnick uno
dei più grandi diciamo social
engineering
p
non a caso ci dice che un hacker è uno
che passava un sacco di tempo manipolare
solitamente questa cosa come dicevo
accade di notte in cui non la calma e la
tranquillità per studiarsi dei sistemi
l'impegno e non basta ci serve qualcosa
che ci dia la motivazione ed è spesso
per una per la curiosità la curiosità
che secondo
alcuni anche una grande teca comunque
innata della della mente di un hacker è
estremamente importante la curiosità di
capire cosa c'è dietro un sistema cosa
c'è dietro un'idea cosa c'è dietro un
concetto
non sappiamo su cosa impegnarci
questo ovviamente un concetto che non a
caso wozniak co creatori di epo co
fondatore di apple
e comunque anche uno dei primi hacker
americani appunto dice che noi nasciamo
come esseri umani questa promozione
questa propensione quanto ci circonda
siamo effettivamente
curiosissimi
abbiamo parlato di t ne manca un terzo
che estremamente importante che è la
passione
se non siamo appassionate di un
argomento è estremamente difficile
impegnarci per comprenderlo meglio è
estremamente difficile
quando abbiamo un enigma una sfida che
può essere affrontare un sistema o
comunque sia affrontare un concetto o un
attacco oppure forzare la mente di una
persona
un esempio può essere anche nei film di
matrix in cui la gente smith cerca di
forzare la mente primo affairs dobbiamo
essere appassionati di quello che
andiamo a esplorare che foraggio la
nostra curiosità
infatti diciamo la passione come
ingrediente è quella cosa che alimenta
la nostra passione quella cosa che
alimenta la nostra voglia di impegnarci
citando quindi margherita hack se noi ci
troviamo di fronte un enigma una sfida e
per un hacker è normale trovarsi di
fronte a queste sfide
dobbiamo stare attenti a tenere il
nostro cervello allenato e quindi non
cedere alla pigrizia mantenere i clan
vostra curiosità e questo può farlo solo
ed esclusivamente la passione
quando ita d
difesa per alcune clienti in ambito anti
security
è capire qual è l'impegno la motivazione
di un attaccante capire se
effettivamente può essere spinto a stare
lì ea verificare un sistema finché la
falla è da un punto di vista diciamo
della scienza della computer science un
elemento estremamente importante
per farvi un esempio
qualche mese fa eravamo medio oriente
con un collega il nostro sistema
bersaglio era scritto in arabo per cui
per me era una scatola con delle
bellissime disegni e lo capiranno il
senso di quel che succederà
l'attività della la due settimane il
venerdì sera della prima settimana non
erano ancora una notte
chiacchierata con delle persone
di questi una macchinetta del caffè a
un quarto però dopo mondo l'intuizione
mezz'ora dopo stavamo guardando i
sorgenti di questi stand decide lanci
dentro tutto grazie all'intuizione ea
quella curiosità che una settimana di
fronte un computer hanno acquisito tutte
quelle informazioni che ci servivano per
poter generare la nostra intuizione
per fare un esempio classico vediamo una
mela
potrei dire fuori l'esempio di newton ma
possiamo anche dire fuori lese e steve
jobs è buona qual è il concerto di
intuizione che c'è stato mettere insieme
il concetto del personal computer
sviluppato appunto da quasi nacca come
suo hobby come sua passione come sua
curiosità nello studiare quelle strane
macchine
mansioni che jobs non ha presa dalla
ferocia cioè avere un'interfaccia
grafica una cosa intuitiva che tutte le
persone potevano effettivamente avere
computer a casa e ora ce l'abbiamo anche
in tasca tra poco ci ho anche addosso ho
addosso in cui la pole per cui questa è
stata l'intuizione che tuttora ne stiamo
subendo anche lei come utenti
cos'è quindi l'intuizione l'infezione in
questo caso prendendo anche quella che è
la definizione della
young ma anche diciamo quella che può
essere intesa con più creatività
se prendiamo la dimissione di creatività
attribuita a pareto che è creare nessi
nuovi tra elementi noti l'intuizione fa
appunto questo
perché non è un processo comunque
razionale
abbiamo degli elementi
che vengono combinati in maniera nuova
ci viene proposta questa idea
e da qui viene fuori l'intuizione e poi
noi o di
capirà perché c'è pure da questa cosa si
spiegherà traversi preferirà
qui il discorso è benissimo
l'intuizione utile per una gara è utile
in generale anche per una per culturale
come facciamo quindi a
ogni al momento giusto c'è tanto lavoro
dietro non è non sono cose che vengono
nell'immediato vanno la nostra mente il
nostro inconscio ho preparato
dobbiamo diventare quindi tutto questo
per il nostro impegno per studiare
quelli che sono gli argomenti per
studiare i sistemi non riusciamo a
compromettere un sistema se prima non
abbiamo capito a fondo magari studiando
le sue regole quindi come magari passare
13 andare oltre
tramite la nostra curiosità che ci
spinge a vediamo cosa c'è dietro a
questo concetto
ultima in un'ultima tramite la mozione
che è quello che ci dà quel carburante
quella voglia quella forza di poter
continuare per terry di a che funziona
un sistema per cui voglio lasciarvi con
questa bellissima citazione di jobs
abbiate il coraggio di seguire il vostro
cuore
le vostre passioni e sempre anche il
nostro intuito grazie